plan against DK here everybody should
fear DK everybody okay Wow hmm maybe we
could turn into a queen pawn opening if
that's the case then the sea pond is not
too happy I'm going to switch gears work
with this structure the night will be
rerouting to g3 let's get this pond
Vance in before f4 night here and here
maybe I think this is a step in the
that's so good direction I think because
with this structure and how it's
staggered right now f4 is the likely
pond break for white there's already a
night here once Castle the rook will be
there supporting it in the decision to
bring the bishop to this b7 square I'm
just not so sure about so in
anticipation of Bishop b2 I want to make
sure that I have d4 reinforced and once
it's reinforced then I'm really not
going to have to worry about the bishop
being on b2 it's just it turn out to be
biting on a rock it can only be broken
down just a little bit with the f4 but I
have have it's secured I'm pretty sure
enough now what about this light square
bishop
I don't know that I want to allow Bishop
to c4 so let's do this in Bishop c4 and
I'm gonna do this because I want to take
into account maybe the bishop Bishop to
b5 check and I don't want to have my
structure ruined hmm throw a question to
it see if I can get that light squared
bishop for night if it goes back here
that's actually a reasonable move okay
however maybe I could just take it and
then play b5 let's try this I want to
over take that pawn on c4 or at the very
least maybe get in beef or something if
there is this capture why tunnels the
pawns but my rook is brought to life and
I could look forward to playing let's
say my pawn up here one day okay so I
have the a file opened up pressure can
be placed on this pond I could defend
with my queen in a couple ways I might
want to look into this advance I'm
making a lot of pawn those however hang
on hang on right there I think I've gone
far enough and I should focus on
development making too many pawn moves
so focusing on development here if I
bring my Bishop out there is this Knight
f5 move which is annoying so I think
it's important to watch out for that v 6
pawn is responsible for boxing out the
knight
and well you know instead of this c4
idea instead it's going to be this one
day my night might want to make the
journey to c3 where it's very very good
hmm maybe I could do a rook lift
followed by a queen over to the a file
if I go here then there's a pawn push
discovered attack on my rook so I'm
anticipating a3 is gonna be played so
maybe a rook lifts to this square and
then in response to this push I could
play here I think I like that
okay I just want to watch out for this
pawn break I'm not seeing it happening
so I'm gonna keep my Bishop around here
I you know I did this move so that the
knight doesn't make use of f5 so I'm not
having to play bishop here and have it
get hit but the other thing is that I
don't want to eventually develop my
Bishop out here my knight - let's say e7
and then have the bishop play to h6 I
want to have my bishop in a spot to
watch out for these weakened squares
that were created as a result of playing
g6 now another thing that I have to be
aware of is what
okay well
I'm gonna play Queen here I'm assuming
Queen here is gonna be played I want to
be able to challenge that Queen with
Queen here whoa I didn't expect that
okay well I can't take Mike I don't want
to have this be file open up I'm gonna
play this instead watch out for these
light squares and try and show that this
pond is going to turn out to be a target
I have one minute to do it now that I
could be a bit more assured of the pond
structure I could go a bit quicker so
castle rook to e8 pinpoint this and
actually instead of castling I'm going
to run with this move king f7 I don't
want to be lured away from the pressure
on this pond and I do not want to take
on this square because that is just
going to help out with White's defense
of a4 I'm trying to make that a target
okay and well I better put a question to
that Queen there is no fork over here
have to be aware of the potential for
Knight b5 stuff but I really seeing that
I just want to throw a question to this
Queen with Knight here and then just get
my knight back out of the way and get
ready to win this pond I think by force
it's gonna be one these uh let's hit it
right now these pawns right here are
pretty much cancelling out both of these
Knights so I'm viewing these three
points here as taking out six pawn push
come back and then it's hit a third time
so let's do this trade I have enough on
it I'm taking with my rooks cuz I don't
want to mention I don't want to
eventually run into a pin and I want to
have my knight pinned and then lastly I
think putting pressure on c2 since that
is the base point and I could do that
with the maneuver it could be captured
but then this pawn the b-pawn becomes a
passed a pond so let's do this
sneaked up if pawn push here I come back
I want to maintain control over this
square so I come back if I take I lose
control
so these Knights are still out of play
and now these Knights have to go back
here the last step is to maybe somehow
put pressure on this guy again so I was
talking earlier that I could be making
use of this square and now what let's
get some King position maybe you know it
so let's get Mike King all the way up to
a c5 King position this Knight is tied
down if there's a pawn push here I meet
it with a pawn push here or do i oh now
that's interesting and good-bye
interesting there I mean good because
guess where my bishop has to do it has
to look like an idiot look at the clown
in the corner 18 seconds I have to run
over back here now and I'm gonna do that
by coming to oh what's that Bishop up -
oh I'm dropping stuff I gotta come over
here their bishops going wild oh come on
King you could do it you could do it you
could do at King position King position
King position go I'm gonna take that
even though I'm dropping a bunch of
black pawns now just working out this
work out I'm gonna try to make this work
- passed pawns just got to go quick
let's go this is not working well the
bishop tricky Knights watch out for the
tricky Knights here pawn push can I
chase that night away next night here
I'm getting something that pawn Queens
if the Knights are off okay now it's
actually queening
okay no time haha fire oh man good game
um okay let's uh slip that one let's go
back home here and buy home I mean move
one so right here is my first suggestion
good game blissful very good game right
down to the wire I think you were
winning in that in Game two as we got
into time pressure let's see I don't
know you can't I don't know about the
bishop coming here cuz you're just
biting at a rock so I think you're
saving yourself a move by not going with
this anymore
I think the pawn break to focus on is f4
and your Bishop will be ideally placed
to come out in this direction or at
least support f4 so that's the first
thing to know and another thing is that
recognize this position right here you
have a lot of development in and maybe
you should look to open the position up
there was a move that I'm not so sure I
referenced during the game but right
here Knight h4 eyeing f5 and preparing
an F push I still need one two three
moves before I'm castled and it's not so
easy actually I kind of view it as like
I need four moves before I'm castled
because the knight coming into f5 that's
scary I think I'd be needing g6 Knight
Bishop move and then only then castle so
I think looking to that even right here
even even right here still looking into
this f4 push would be interesting I
think that's the bulk of it those are
the book that's the those are my main
suggestions right here becomes awkward
you have the right idea to try and get
this pawn push
got it in but it does become a target
and in this endgame I do stand better in
this position that a pond seems like it
is going to fall my technique with
putting pressure on the pond was good
but your your way of getting to the c-4
square and get him getting active over
here was very nice that was good so you
did good
playing down upon in that end game
you're saying that you're typing my way
that you're off at the end game I'm not
so sure about that yeah I mean there's
there's clearly some good moves good
ideas that were shown to me there so
it's in its again you know you have to
consider the time element too so not
easy to be playing accurately and fast
in game but I thought it was a good game
it was a really nice a lot of fun to
play action of shouldn't have gotten
that in the end you defended see to your
night on g3 turned out to be a pain
because you got your H pond involved
that was good
and then your bishop for some reason I
was thinking was your bishop that was
tied up my nights are sitting pretty but
this one is a big clown what is he doing
he needs some help
he's doing nothing he's just sitting in
a hall and like that's it he has nothing
better to offer than just sitting pretty
right there on c3 that's about all he's
doing huh okay